we are all staying at home a lot more
lately we are
limited in our travel options but it's
summer so
how can we treat ourselves with the
ultimate summer
staycation i am joined now by style and
beauty expert jenn
phallic who has some ideas jen how are
you
hello i'm good how are you i'm good
except
i'm at home and i want to have a summer
what can you do at home glamping in your
backyard
emphasis on the campaign you sleep out
in a tent it feels so
funny we did it one night a couple weeks
ago with my kids and it was
so much fun but then we need the me time
right how can you self-care
when we don't have a spa have an at-home
spa day
close the door to the bathroom take a
longer shower than usual steam your face
do a hair mask
so how else can you get that summer glow
at home we teamed up with rock skincare
and their spokesperson jen
phallic to find out it's called revive
and glow
daily serum with vitamin c and it's
awesome
tell me why tell me more rock did a
clinical study with 34 women and
every woman who used the product had
brighter and tighter skin in just four
weeks
so where do i get it you can get it at
target and target.com
as well this is under 25. great the wind